en otras noticias de la pandemia en
france 24 hungría firmó un acuerdo para
comprar la vacuna rusa sputnik que kobe
de 19 es el primer país de la unión
europea en hacerlo
rompiendo filas con el resto del bloque
que está recibiendo lotes aprobados en
conjunto en medio de la frustración por
los retrasos en el suministro de
medicamentos
las autoridades alemanas reportaron 859
víctimas mortales por kobe 19 en las
últimas 24 horas así el país sobrepasó
los 50 mil fallecidos desde el inicio de
la pandemia sin embargo van en caída los
contagios del instituto robert koch de
virología informó 17 mil 800 nuevos
positivos frente a 22.300 del viernes
y colombia sobrepaso el jueves las
50.000 muertes por coronavirus al
confirmar el ministerio de salud de 395
fallecimientos el país se enfrenta a la
saturación de las redes hospitalarias en
las regiones más afectadas por el
elevado aumento de contagios y se acerca
a los 2 millones de casos confirmados